today we're talking about free training
automation and optimizing storage costs
i'm stephanie wong and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest lane c news there's not
much better than
free since the start of the year we've
introduced a number of opportunities for
you to grow your skills
and we wanted to bring them together
into one place
whether you're just getting started on
the cloud or looking for ways to
challenge yourself
and collect skills badges bookmark this
collection of training
opportunities and check back regularly
automation is now available for everyone
with app sheet automation
app sheet our no code development
platform leverages google ai to make it
easier to automate business
processes letting you focus more on high
impact work
and less on manual tasks check out the
getting started video
and reclaim your time
storage is a critical component of any
cloud-based infrastructure
without a place to store and serve your
data databases won't work
compute can't run and networks have
nowhere to put the data they're carrying
so it's no surprise that you want to
make sure you're optimizing your storage
costs
this guide will give you advice on what
to look for and identify ways you can
save some cash
sometimes a picture is worth a thousand
words and that's where these cheat
sheets come in handy
our own priyanka vergadia has built a
number of guides
that help developers visually navigate
critical decisions
whether it's determining the best way to
move to the cloud or
deciding on the best storage options if
you want to read more about these
announcements or
see a full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you